Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
Let's get started. We've got a lot of questions, a few questions that came in.
So those of you that are on here, if you have any other questions, make sure you chat them in.
Reminder for everybody again that announcements are on the members site.
So if there's changes after cancel a Zoom call, make changes to different things.
Try to get those announcements right on the main page of the member site and you can also self-schedule from the website or the member site.
Pretty personal calls.
Okay, first question. After over three years of basically no change, this person's cancer, the lump in my breast has come to life.
Since losing all my weight the first year after diagnosis, it's been very easy to feel and it's always felt the same.
The lump in the breast verb had rigid.
Now, however, it's got a small area that is hard as a rock and it seems to be attaching to skin visibly.
It's like it's going to burst through soon.
Seems similar to the attachment that creates the inverted nipple.
I'm so scared. I don't know what to make of it.
If I go to the regular doctor, they will push hard for surgery.
But there's no alternative doctor close by that I know of who would monitor it as an open wound if I try black sand.
I would feel assured it was a positive response to the MMS protocol I've been doing this last month.
Except unfortunately, I've also been failing at my diet a lot recently.
So could be pushing a bad change. I just don't know.
Still feel great physically getting some new blood work and a Dutch test in about a month.
Then we'll also get more information in the meantime I'm scared straight back into a strict diet.
Do such changes in a lump always mean bad news.
I've been looking online for a source of black sand, but I can't find one yet.
Do you have any leads for this also a loss as to how doctor fight a doctor locally who can monitor the black sand?
Yeah, you're going to have a very difficult time fighting a local doctor who's going to monitor a black sand, topical black sand protocol simply because it's so infrequently done.
But to answer some of these prior questions here is doing black sand on a breast tumor always the right thing to do.
The answer, my answer to that would be no.
We've had multiple patients do a black sand protocol on their breast over the years.
Some had a good experience with it, some had a bad experience with it.
Or it was good for a period of time and then it just seemed to just make a mess of things it's very difficult to manage.
You're always cleaning it it seems like it's always coming out it seems often it seems never ending, which is different than doing black sand on a topical melanoma.
There's always an end point with melanoma.
Though I've had people do it multiple multiple times on that same spot still pulling the cancer out.
There always was an end point and it always in my experience ended well with breast cancer it's a little bit different.
It's just it's just different in many different ways.
So I don't know that black sand is the right thing to do for that reason.
Secondly, black sand is not going to have an effect on a cancer that is several millimeters below the surface.
So if the if the cancer breaks through the skin wall and you do have an open wound then a person theoretically can use topical things on it.
Black sand that thing to go to right away well for reasons I already stated it may not be so you got to think long and hard before you're going to do that.
The other negative black sand black sand can be very painful.
Some people have done it on their rest or on a melanoma and it had not had any pain but it does open up the world more and it will draw.
So there's pros and cons to doing it so don't take that don't take.
Don't make your decision thinking that that's going to be it's going to be for sure the answer and I want to find somebody to do black sand.
So that being said on their topical things a person could do if the cancer is near the surface.
Prior to a cancer breaking through the tissue from an alternative perspective and then last comment on this is that I would caution anybody that is in this situation just this person who wrote this is to not.
You know I'm a question you know why are you completely against doing anything standards of care wise.
Of course standards of care in this situation depending on how big the masses there's all sorts of dependings there.
I would want to do a mastectomy now I know there's a lot of women there is completely a hundred percent against doing mastectomy we've had people that have.
Ben that way and have done black sand and fought it for a month to years and then finally succumbed to doing a mastectomy and I.
You'd have to ask these people directly do you wish you would have just what did a mastectomy a year ago I don't know what their answer would be I think everybody has to feel like they tried everything before they did that.
But the other the next question is is are such changes in a lump always bad news.
I would say that if the lump is getting larger or it's moving in a direction that's growth I would say so I would say yes in that sense it's bad news.
It's much it would be worst news if it was moving towards the chest wall so moving towards the surface is better news than a cancer moving towards the chest wall as far as the breast cancer goes.
But yeah we should have a consultation about this to go into a depth of everything the changes that you're seeing.
Clearly getting blood work done and is the right thing to do get some testing done and also getting back on the straight narrow different things is a good thing to do always too.
By diet recommendations you said to stay away from bone broth because it's high in glutamine and high and also to stay away from high histamine foods.
I'm trying to heal my gut right now and I'm looking at a vegan pea protein that contains glutamic acid and histidine not sure if they're the same as glutamine and histamine.
Well histidine is not the same as histamine and glutamic acid will convert to glutamine so you could say glutamic acid and glutamine are the same histidine and histamine are not the same.
But so you can't use this so I wouldn't do that.
Now if a person don't okay so should every cancer patient stay away from glutamine in their supplements?
The answer is in my book would be yes unless the person is in a state of you know their cancer is in a state of remission they've been doing really well
and they want to do glutamine to heal their gut for a short period of time.
Then I'd say that's I'm sure you're most likely going to be fine with that.
It would be you know contract indicative if the person's going to go on a glutamine supplement for a longer period of time.
Now most good practitioners that are working at healing somebody's gut don't necessarily put them on high dose glutamine for a long period of time anyhow.
So a couple weeks on a higher dose glutamine to try to heal the gut can be beneficial. Why does glutamine heal the gut?
Because it stimulates growth stimulates growth regrowth of new epithelial cells that lie in the gut.
So it helps grow new cells while it helps grow new cells.
You have cancer cells in the gut or something too.
So it also depends slightly on the type of cancer or so the person was dealing with colon cancer.
And they might be in full remission from colon cancer I don't think I ever use glutamine.
But if they're dealing if they had breast cancer and they're in full remission then I think using glutamine for a short period of time is fine.
There's other things a person can do to heal their gut without using glutamine.
So you know there's there's tons of different herbs that are gut healing herbs that are not going to stimulate growth too.
So something to look into those things too.
Dr. Chi the creator of myoman comes to my area annually and charges a nominal fee for a consult.
So I went to see him the other day.
He recommended three of his products for me to prevent recurrence and to help with estrogen dominance.
I'm already taking myoman.
What I said in my cheek swab, I would like you to tell me the doses of these what would be best to go along with everything else.
I've taken an individualized program.
Should I include a capsule of each one of these with my cheek swab?
The answer that we yes that would be best to make it easier for you or something to look up at the internet muscle tests from there.
But we best if you did include a capsule of that and just mark the baggy that you put them in.
Have you had other patients consult with him or heard any feedback?
No, I have not had anybody that is personally consulted with him so I don't know.
I spoke to him at a seminar years and years ago, but that was, oh gosh, I was over a decade ago.
He seems knowledgeable and honest.
That's good.
So we'll look at what he's recommended.
Most of his products contain Chinese herbs and we've had luck with the myoman before.
Is a ritherto okay to use monk most monk fruit has a ritherto.
So ritherto is a sugar alcohol.
And sugar alcohol really came into use during the days.
I was probably was 15, 20 years ago that I was that diet going around everywhere.
The guy was supposed to be really I was kind of like the kind of like a keto diet, but he wasn't getting anybody to keep toast.
I wasn't the purpose and forget his name starts with a pee I think.
But it was eating, you know, more like carnivore diet, but it wasn't really a responsible carnivore diet.
I ate a whole lot of fat and but the people were losing weight like crazy because they just were eating carbs.
But you know, if you have sweet tooth, what are you going to eat?
You know, to satisfy your sweet tooth, well, that's where the sugar alcohols really came into use.
And they were put into like protein bars and all that kind of stuff.
And you know, as many as a lot of studies on sugar alcohols and what they do, the benefit is is they don't for the most part, they don't spike your glucose levels.
But they have other negatives to them.
So it's found that they can disrupt different metabolic processes and long term use of them can cause all sorts of problems.
But for the most part, it's in fairly high concentration of use.
So, you know, that's why I think in our binder, I have some information about using sugar alcohols in general.
It's, it all has to do with, you know, with quantity, like so many things have to do with quantity.
You know, if off it's okay to use that, then we're going to use that in everything and we're going to, you know, eat tons of milligrams of sugar alcohols within over time if you do it every day, it could cause issues.
But having, you know, that once in a while is not going to be a problem.
It's certainly not going to be a problem as far as a driver of the cancer.
So it can be out, you can lead to other healthcare issues, high dose use of it over a long period of time.
But I've not seen any data that shows that sugar alcohols promote cancer growth.
Or it certainly doesn't break down to glucose. It is used as a fuel source by the mitochondria.
So, and by cancer cells, so it's not going to be an issue with cancer.
So, yeah, you're safe to use that. You're safe to use sugar substitutes.
You're safe to use sugars that break down slower, you know, and there's, you know, there's the idea is you're not getting these glucose spikes when you eat something.
When you get these glucose spikes, when you eat something, it's just fuel for a cancer to pick up and to gobble on.
So, that's what we're trying to be careful of is those glucose spikes.
Sugar alcohols don't do that.
So, they can't be a good substitute for a sweet tooth.
Somebody stayed away from sugar trying to be on a ketogenic type nine.
Any other questions?
All right. Well, we will talk to everybody next week. Thanks for being an unknown that we're all praying for you.
Also, use your prayer, that prayer request form on the site if you have any specific prayer requests forms.
All right. Bye, everybody.